はいこんにちははじめ社長ですいつでしたっけ結構最近だした道があるんですけど僕
太ったって話が結構経ってるの一か月前か
えっと1か月ラインで僕すっぽりましたって言うでお渡したと思うんですよあの時の
体重が今見返したんですけども712.1kg で僕その動画で言いました
痩せました必ずモテる体型はでやりますと言いました
そしてあれから1か月号見せるぞ俺のこの1か月の努力が見せてやるからな
シマジ1ケほんと俺もうほんとどれだけがんばった言葉の店ってありますけどねあの
リマ
[音楽]
me
ハイターハイターがみるみるたいくださいいただきたいはいはい
はい60号店15キログラム
ああもう何もしてないからね
[音楽]
はいはいおれ画像今のタイズでい紛れもない65.2キロでございます
はい私は宣言した通りこの1か月だねモデル太平に
戻りました多分皆さん気づかなかったと思うんですけども結構この1か月花木いろいろ
やってましたからね俺も感動的にも完全にお腹ももなんてなりましたし
何だろうなあなんか
もやしに戻っちゃったね人って自分よりか頭がシュッとスラッとした自分が好きだった
んでこのままもしれないせいか食い続けると本当んにただのデブになっちゃうなと思っ
て
もう自分で絶対痩せなきゃって言い聞かせて結構とんでもない方法で痩せましたという
わけで今回の痩せた方法というふうにご紹介しようと思います
ビッ狩り狩りは代価だけど結構細くなったよ
ただ僕が燃やせって言われ始めてた時期ぐらい貼ったら細くなっていました1か月で何
て言おうとしたんだろう僕の信者のモデル体型が65.7キログラムなのでモデル体型
でございます70人昨日から65キロまで減らしたかな記録は1か月で7キロ減らした
んですけども
実は増え始めて思ったんですけどもうなかなか体重ってを連れもんじゃないです
僕もすぐにパッと落ちるぞ
ってこうなんか落ちないなぁと思って頑張ってるんですけども気づいたら徐々に落ちて
来てたみたいな感じで沖合でや逆とかほんと楽じゃないってよ絶対マジでやってみたら
大変だと思うしねこうね体の危機を感じててもやってたんであっちゃー死にそうです
ただ真似しない方がいいですまずはですけど僕運動する系やそんなにないので運動は
ほぼ知っていませんために刺されてパッケージに
行ったぐらいで基本的にそれが2部は何もしてないんですけども結局ねなんで太る
かっていうとご飯を食べるからなんです
ごはんたらて動けばいいんですけど僕5買ったけど動かないから多分太ったわけでそれ
は果たしてどうやって止めたかっていう
こちら大金の動画でも紹介したんですけどもコバラサポートと後特茶特徴は
コバラサポートで僕はここまできたと言っても過言ではありませんだの痩せようって
決めたときからずっと特産飲んでたんですけどもとっちゃあ飲んでもねをお腹を受けて
くれるんですよ
飲んでもお腹は減るんでそこでちょっと考えを切り替えてコバラサポート奴はもう本当
にねアホほど
みました女か着いたと思ったらすぐこれなんだよなと膨らませてご飯をなるべく食べ
ない
最低限食べてるんですけども基本的にを泣かせたら全部コバラサポートを飲んで飲んで
飲んで飲んで飲んで飲みまくってこのドリンクでなんとかお腹起こったを足せるって
いう作戦でねぇ高のず番の特徴が聞いて脂肪が落ちたらとこれでそもそものご飯を食べ
ないという作戦でひたすら体に nikko
をつかせなくてこうどんどん創業としていく作戦でここまでやってまいりました
あのねきついからな頑張りおすすめしないですねかねやっぱね美味しいものを食べない
ところが二散々で自分との闘いでしたここで食っちゃダメだなみたいなこともありつっ
てちょっと気合でなんとかモノホン65 k ちゃ
僕の中なんですけどもたら痩せるのはこれが最強だなと思いました
宣伝モデル体型まで戻りますといってまぁ1ヶ月まで出来たなぁ
1か月で無事に体重を7キロ落としてモデル体験ができたというお話でございました
本当にやってないと来た人はすごいおすすめですけどもガッツはしますあんまりまでし
ない方が良いと思いますがそういう作戦も上がるよというお話でございましたもう一人
だけねーなー皆さんやされてしまったんですけど
を燃やしたわ
言わないで
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ